this is high fashion and this is
commercial high fashion commercial
that's all I know
today we're gonna post the high fashion
models for the first time
high fashion modeling looks hard looks
very uncomfortable pauses
I'm an avid watcher of the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show that's the extent of
my runway knowledge as a high-fashion
short is can't really interest an
artistic element to it or it feels a
little more like elevated and I'm
becoming a girl laying on the floor and
you can barely see the outfit but it's
high-fashion I know that everyone's
probably wearing very expensive clothing
Couture I believe the fall for the range
between naked and a hot tub with like a
necklace or a high-end apartment all
skinny
everyone has crazy bone structure and
jaw lines in high fashion and I don't
really have that at all being confident
giving a smoldering look they just look
like they don't have a care in the world
they're just like it looks so effortless
I'm excited to see like what I learned
from the photographer's and how while I
take direction I'm gonna look like I'm
far too most of the time who knows maybe
we're gonna have an anxiety attack
you're gonna kill it hoping that
stepping outside of my comfort zone well
maybe open up the opportunities to
looking cool we have great photographers
we have great makeup artists here today
that are gonna hopefully help us a lot
my name is Brandon Sosa I'm Arthur Gallo
our concept today we're getting and you
guys in a campaign and fashion brand
environment before so it's kind of mr.
Bhagavan Gucci patterns like colors lots
of props busy living room vibe and the
other sounds gonna be a simple red
backdrop very poppy little bit more
minimal I'm sure will be a few
challenges today
sometimes preconceived notions on how
you're supposed to behave as a model a
learning lesson today will be that less
is more the makeup was a lot crazier
than usual just because it's supposed to
be high-fashion our faces are a lot more
mannequin like because it's supposed to
be sleek you're supposed to not look
real almost something I've never
experienced before living the life of
high-end I couldn't get a babysitter for
Marty he came along and we just
incorporated him in the huge I don't
think I did in Milan photos because
that's more commercial the whole time I
was just like all right who the [ __ ] am
I looking at
alright who's this [ __ ] okay yeah they
felt like my face it can look bored and
so a lot of times in there like look up
I don't want to look there like the
whole time my face was just saying play
dead that was my process I feel very
self-conscious and really bad teeth
Crona so I'm never something that's
comfortable smiling so it was really
nice in these because I just got to be
like that in the eyes which is my
natural go-to anyways I passion dead
inside dead in the eyes the photographer
asked me like give me attitude I was
like nam like hmm like is a give me
attitude really okay you just walked off
the set I think I'm more comfortable
with commercial photography where if
you're holding something you're late I
[Music]
think the hardest part of the day was
just what to do with my hands every
little movement matters especially
seeing like oh my god it closed my hand
like
and they were like look more masculine
I'm like okay what you normally sit in a
chair you're not like do I look
masculine you just sit a little bit of
struggle finding positions I always
question myself if I'm gonna look lousy
or like my legs are gonna look weird
unconventional poses one foot in the
couch one foot touching the floor while
I'm holding my suit jacket everything
was just like no it made me second-guess
all my opposing skills you feel like
your leg was in the right place but then
it comes off weird on camera so they
knew exactly where to put us so I had to
tweak me and move me exactly where they
wanted me until they found the right
position when I first started I was a
little bit nervous and then once we got
like those first few shots off I got
much more relaxed and just felt way more
comfortable I was able to just like give
a natural feel now I know I can do this
or this or even this you were killed in
in the red snack he was just like bam
bam bam bam bam bam bam yeah that's cuz
they show me what to do and I was just
like okay I can do that you just kind of
moved me in a spot and I felt like I
couldn't move and then I thought Jeremy
like kill it so I wanted to relax more
imposes felt much more rigid and defined
which I really enjoyed they're a lot
more dramatic and with all these poses
you feel a little bizarre and awkward
but then you see the photo the group
shot was crazy it totally looked like we
just stepped out of a Gucci at so like
sick pose be at it's candid initially he
said so-and-so look at someone so her
looking at each other we gonna stop
laughing kind of awkward you're just
staring that other person across from me
it felt awkward but when you saw the
photo didn't look like you were looking
at the person they were good at
communication sometimes photographers
will just kind of shoot and then you're
like oh do I look good okay and they're
taking pictures but it totally like xed
out what I was worried about the
composition of the pictures was really
great and you just totally put a lot of
time and effort into the way they posed
you and the way they shot it it was
really neat
I was like you know what I've spent 26
years seeing inside my head and being
insecure this new year I finally decided
to just own who the [ __ ] you are have
fun with this and what the [ __ ] I had no
idea what to expect when we started
shooting these I don't necessarily
picture myself as a beautiful person but
when I saw these photos it just came out
so good beyond my wildest imagination I
am going out to the store and buying and
maybe tongues today I'm obsessed I felt
really special beautiful I felt like
over the top I'm just like don't talk to
me right now this actually turned out a
lot better than I thought it would for
like my own photos because I recently
just shaved my head and I'm still like
kind of insecure about it
seeing these cool photos with my phone's
head now it makes me a more comfortable
about it too I enjoyed it it was so good
at their job I feel like my self-esteem
went up a small rung
I might learn to love myself down the
road but not after today do you feel
list cache let's trash doing this I was
like I have like up there I think I'm
like that people like a gold trash bag
I'm definitely still trash but I'm like
an elevated trash bag that can hold
anything you put in it
growing up I was probably a little bit
intimidated by how men are perceived in
the media and how men's bodies look and
I compared that to myself a lot to be
able to own Who I am and be happy and
confident with my body that was really
rewarding because I proved to myself
that you don't have to look like
Hercules to experience something as
amazing as high fashion photography I'm
so used to kind of watching and looking
behind the scenes so it was really fun
for me to kind of have the opportunity
to be in front of the camera and have
fun and have some photos that I'm gonna
cherish for the rest of my life and
hopefully someone else will share some
too so waiting it was really fun for us
we've been doing a lot of projects
together this is the first time we
really were all put in front
at the same time and it was really fun
to get to kind of like laugh and also
try new things with everyone right there
you did slay we all did it just looks
great Chris yeah I love how like we all
posed individually but like overall like
we're all connected we're not just like
holding each other or like you know
we're just like everyone doing their own
thing but we magically look like we're
kids and that I would totally do this
again I wen thousand percent have a new
profile pic I can't wait to post it and
see these likes rollin I would
definitely try this again because now
that I have bit of experience I think it
would be a lot easier the second time
Marty was a better high-fashion model
today better than all of us actually
with the right team the sound stage
professional photographer the hair and
makeup wardrobe and all that you can all
look good everyone like my fashion
highest fashion pose I'm running to
jack-in-the-box
[Music]